good morning 47
we have a lead on the shadow client ica
white hats
have traced the anonymous data received
by our clients to one olivier hall
brilliant young hacktivist and suspect
in a dozen cases of cyber vandalism
using onion rooting with
state-of-the-art encryption paul went to
a lot of trouble to stay untraceable
she is good but we are better
her digital trail has led us to a remote
farm in colorado
where satellite footage has revealed
what appears to be the training camp for
a private militia
led by an already registered target sean
rose
australian environmental terrorist and
explosives expert
wanted for a series of public bombings
rose was spotted near the scene of
thomas cross's kidnapping
which makes him our prime suspect for
the shadow climate
spurred by eric soders the ica board of
directors has asked us to infiltrate the
farm and eliminate shawn rose
along with three other prominent militia
members ezra berg
a retired mossad interrogator penelope
graves
former interpol anti-terror analyst and
finally
maya parvati
i'll be honest with you 47 i consider
eric soda's reasoning hasty and
ill-advised
now we cannot go against the wishes of
the board but we can conduct
our own investigation whether a direct
threat to the ica or not
we need to know the shadow client's true
agenda
i will leave you to prepare
welcome to colorado 47 the militia has
taken up hq at an old apricot farm
and appear to be training for a series
of coordinated strikes
ranging from cyber attacks to full-blown
guerrilla warfare
the shadow client appears to unite
specialists and radicals from all over
the map
mercenaries and terrorists hackers and
spies joined by an
unknown common cause satellite scans
indicate that the command room is below
ground
inside an old tornado shelter only rose
appears to have access however
so to get inside you will need to get
creative
this environment is hostile and highly
alert
so tread carefully good luck 47
uh
legendary mossad operative who
specializes in chemical interrogation
techniques
is here at the compound to interrogate a
prisoner
my notes indicate he set up a makeshift
drug lab in a garage
and it looks like he's spending a lot of
his time in the basement
could be an opportunity there 47.
how are you talking about it i was just
at the security station watching the
feeds there's this creepy guy
interrogating the hostage
wears like a 3d printed mask oh yeah
that must be
bird oh yeah
like things
drug induced hypnosis
god hey you
stop this
who specializes in chemical
interrogation techniques
is here at the compound to interrogate a
prisoner
my notes indicate he set up a makeshift
drug lab in a garage
and it looks like he's spending a lot of
his time in the basement
could be an opportunity there 47
[Music]
hey
how are you talking about i was just at
the security station watching these
oh
they don't like to mark up their
patience
flip through
so uh
austin he wears a 3d printed mask oh
yeah
wait a minute
in the world
is
hey oh god damn it hey nicest
make this one
yes
good work keep your eyes open
please
you're very lucky that individual is
still freezing this is your mess
oh you are so dead you little wanker
[Music]
oh
so
what that's that's it again did you see
that
i've never seen anything like that
before
wow
like sure
hmm man i thought i heard something
chicken it out
over
oh
catch that turn up for nothing
oh
hey don't wave that around
do
just cross your fingers that the damn
thing doesn't fire again
rose gets a lot of important phone calls
that is penelope graves acclaimed
anti-terror analyst
strange to see her as part
yeah so what's wrong with the relay
station anyway
the switch is loose old model if it
happens again i guess we can
weld it in place or something sure if it
comes to that
hey i'm kind of lost here i mean it's
literally my first weekend
i already got chewed out by rose what's
the deal with him
well to be honest he gives me the creeps
i don't much appreciate his methods i'm
more of
a cedar whites of their eyes kind of
salty
and the others i mean how's the general
consent
the boss picked him for a reason that's
good enough
that is penelope graves acclaimed
anti-terror analyst
strange to see her as part of this
sir the walls will be just
hey keep on doing that and you'll be
scraping shrapnel out of your leg
glad you gained your sanity i mean it's
literally my first weekend
i already got chewed out by rose very
charming
i have to say it's a beautiful piece of
work
what's
a battering ram has injured one of the
strike team point man by the name of
burgess
and according to those militiamen maya
parvati oversees training
sounds promising i suggest you
infiltrate the strike team 47
perhaps you can relieve the hapless
point man of his duties
just put your gun away please it's
making me nervous
just cross your fingers that the damn
thing doesn't fail
rose gets a lot of importance
does it
security's in the house
oh
quality
you know i've been thinking in school
they always talk a
that's all good to hear all right head
over to the briefing area
we'll resume in a moment
so
all right people let's get to it burgess
is back
we're finally ready to make this happen
i expect you all to know this by heart
but in case amnesia has set in here's
the sequence
advance to the car with haste eliminate
the passengers
retrieve the briefcase extract
got that and remember speed and accuracy
is the name of the game
all right now go pick up your weapons
and get in position
move out will
stop choking that person right now
there's something else
it's funny thinking about it a weapon
shows you that is some of the worst
shooting i've seen in all my life
all right head over to the briefing area
we'll resume in a moment
so
all right people let's get to it burgess
is back
we're finally ready to make this happen
i expect you all to know this by heart
but in case amnesia has set in here's
the sequence
advance to the car with haste eliminate
the passengers
retrieve the briefcase extract
got that and remember speed and accuracy
is the name of the game
all right now go pick up your weapons
and get in position
move out don't shake your ammo on this
guy
please proceed pretend i'm not here not
a problem
all right let's go again on your marks
ready
set execute
[Music]
take five and find your a game
burgess that's just not good enough
speed
see this needs to improve team's
performance was passable but lacks
coordination
the point is to build up muscle memory a
perfect
sequence of synchronized motion we've
been through
all this before boss [ __ ] will go wrong
we'll need to improvise if you do what i
tell you nothing will go wrong
not on my watch do it again foreign
all right let's go again on your marks
ready
set execute
that's it let loose on that heavy comedy
[Music]
people we'll need to wrap it up and
revise our strategy
maya parvati is down good work
oh [ __ ] oh you were at jordan cross's
funeral huh
whole team moving like clockwork perfect
execution
thomas cross was off-site before his
guards even noticed
mr whatever
seriously anyone know this guy there
will be no
warning shots they're just saying man be
good man
just try and throw your face here again
[Applause]
whatever
crap stop right here
it up you toss up
yeah don't come back
[Applause]
stop right there
i should be going to mexico
[Applause]
[Music]
rose confirmed down nicely done 47
[Music]
i don't know
[Music]
better lock and load
so
well
so
so
it's not his fault they grew up in that
crazy collective farm out in the outback
what were they called
sons of solidarity no they're a bunch of
left-wing
[Applause]
he's there over there double tap
you son of a
[Applause]
i just watched an interview with that
billionaire presidential candidate
last night you know the one with the
famous hairdo
ah that guy seems so well composed and
has
that's a refined academic way to use his
arguments
flanked with well-researched facts and
figures
yeah he's honest and trustworthy
what'd you think i'm gonna pretend i
didn't
i don't even huh whoa slow down
[Applause]
okay
i'm telling you back in the day
my pop screens
[Applause]
hey
man got some strange noises here looking
into it
[Applause]
i'm taking you with me
hey there's room for everyone here man
[Applause]
so
sorry strict orders my friend access
denied
yeah you know the drill
[Applause]
wait a minute
man just heard a strange noise i'm gonna
check it out
please stand by
hey anyone there command we're good
sir this is off limits
that's gonna yeah
drop the body right now
uh
oh man we might have a situation
i'll check the perimeter over
nothing here returning to post
how do you read over command i have an
unidentified
person here confirm command over
[Music]
uh
so
[Applause]
that is ezra berg a former mossad
interrogator
his services are in demand at the moment
don't move
who the guy the guy ezra berg has tied
up in the interrogation room
he's one of the enemies couriers hey
rules they call himself heroes most
bastards
the enemy uses
foreign
foreign
ugh
foreign
ah
don't worry special forces are here
is that a weapon jesus christ
unconscious well done 47
with any luck the perfectionist ezra
berg will want to examine his notes
closely
to figure out what happened
ezra berg has been eliminated good work
47
it's actually quite brilliant in all its
improvised glory
cop director his plane crashed
hey who are you
sir i'm talking to you
i don't
so
so
[Music]
wow
um
[Music]
so
is the enemy
[Music]
and the enemy has to have known about
iago
probably even used that services
come on we have an election breakdown
[Music]
mask that's what it does it's a 3d
printer
it prints things in wait for it
i'm fine
that's what it does it's a 3d printer
it prints things in like
three dimensions i know what it does i
just have a hard time grasping it
could we print out our own weapons sure
maybe a small gun for something really
specific
it's beautiful tech for assassins but
old-school weapons
are still cheaper and more reliable so i
hear rose had his own face scanned for
3d masking after he saw
burke's mask one of the hackers keeps
the face
[Music]
hi i'm penelope graves you look like
you've been part of the crew for a while
wondering how you'll find it here
whatever
i don't much appreciate his methods i'm
more of
a cedar whites of their eyes kind of
soldier remote bombings just seen
so i just found out that he's a tamil
tiger
so this test that rose has planned
seems kind of cruel doesn't it i mean
i'm no softy or anything but it
feels excessive she's got it coming
and nobody can switch sides that great
and just expect to be accepted tessa in
order man
yeah sure i get that like playing on her
interpol like that
i i don't know man but i just hope the
technician knows how to act
she used to be the enemy i don't have
any sympathy for that i'm sure he'll be
fine he's got the badge right yeah he
showed it to me over by the tent
rehearsed his lines too he's taking this
pretty seriously
should be in the clear hey it'll be
interesting to see if she takes that job
don't mind me here
ah it's not helping i wonder
is that better
thank you
wait now try again with the bloody
russians
oh okay uh
wait how about now
um
so you're all set for the sting sure got
a badge in my pocket prep my lines
shouldn't be a problem almost game time
um
you uh think you can hook her gripes is
new
she comes by for two seconds to check on
her work she's paranoid enough to fight
so rose basically wants you to pretend
you're with interpol
uh get her to come with you and then
what i'm supposed to lure her to the
slurry pit and tell her to roll over on
rose and the rest of us
try to get her to turn on us be
interested to see how she reacts
is she going to ask the guys there to
shoot me or will she give up everything
yeah it's a big decision what if she
takes the bait
when it rose is going to find her a
kicker ass i imagine
still nothing so the damn satellite pull
out or something all right
get the signal now
we need back up here i'm off to the
bathroom not feeling
hi there grunt
hey enough with the chokehold
[Music]
again
come on i may have been poisoned
huh
penelope graves we need to talk you're
uh what is this i'll explain everything
the slurry pit it will be in your best
interest
to do as i say i understand
wow
[Applause]
miss graves you recruited back into
interpol
as an insider what i
who are you anyway how did you find me
that is not important
think about this carefully you can
provide us with valuable intel
if you cooperate the agency will
overlook your unfortunate transgression
and what if i refuse huh if i scream and
get the guards here i wouldn't do that
if i were you
might prove unhealthy i'll give you a
few moments to think about it
good work 47 this should give her
something to think about
okay
hey can you just leave me alone for a
few minutes
i've got some thinking to do i'm sure
rose won't mind
think graves how did they get to you
flight out of lion under assumed name
passport provided through delgado and
that punisher
luckily changed clothes at jfk and again
at denver international charred the
passport after leaving the hotel
was
[Applause]
roger that
hey look it's very sweet of you to
follow me around on rosi's request but
oh guess what i'm a big girl i can
handle myself for a few minutes all
right
thank you
think graves how did they get to you
flight out of lyon under assumed name
passport provided through delgado and
that vanisher guy
that's all targets taken care of now
gain access to the tornado shelter
sir you are
okay i need to clear my head and have
some privacy here
look hey whoa
okay thank you
think graves how did they get to you
flight out of line under assumed name
passport provider
delgado and vanish your guy
look clean
now gain access to the tornado shelter
come on
[Music]
so just come back
that's all targets taken care of 47 now
gain access to the tornado shelter
perfect
foreign
uh
[Music]
[Music]
ah this day keeps getting better and
better
yes you are the man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
47. it appears the door to the tornado
shelter is protected by a biometric
lock to gain access you need sean rose's
body
or something equally convincing
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
who the hell are you
stop you know what i don't even care
it's right over here i will be forced to
take action
whatever
i don't talk to this there he is
oh did i tell you i found another one
yesterday
another one oh do tell okay so you know
how rose keeps his desk
tidy like a japanese garden right anyway
someone knocked a pen block
why am i doing this don't we have
security
identify yourself
you don't move
you know what i don't even care
ah i can't deal with it i just can't
the plot thickens someone left in a
hurry
shawn rose was not the shadow client
that much is clear whoever commands the
militia they got out just in time
look around 47
we're getting closer
some kind of network power players
from all sectors familiar faces too
thomas cross klaus strandberg
ether and that's missing banker eugene
cobb
well well there's a name providence
what no
no it can't be the hidden hand
thought they were a myth a hypothesis
nothing more
the idea that a small cabal of king
makers controlling enough corporate and
political leaders
could effectively run the world in
secret maybe not so hypothetical
keep looking 47 we need full disclosure
[Music]
someone's done their homework look how
far it dates back
hayamoto beldingford del vade
the shadow client has been tracking you
for decades now how is that possible
it isn't every one of those missions
were branded as unsolved or accidents
he must have been looking for a pattern
a certain mo
which would mean he knows me well
at least this shortens the list
[Music]
found something sodas
that would mean providence
has infiltrated ica and eric soders
is their operative bastard it all fits
he was the one who persuaded the rest of
the ica board to green light this
operation
this changes everything
get out 47 we got what we came for what
about the shadow clan
he is no longer our primary concern ica
has been compromised
i always wondered if providence was real
but i never actually
i will need to confer with the board but
mark my words 47.
this will have consequences
rosie's gone it was me wasn't it
they tracked me i don't believe it
i took every precaution rose knew the
risks
they all do you did well olivia i am
proud of you
now listen the ica knows about you
they kept you alive because they needed
you and now they don't
we won't talk again not until the storm
is over
i don't like it this man nobody's
capable of
you need to end this now
[Applause]
i ran away as a boy
my friend and i away from that
place we came upon a small farming
community the people
were poor but this woman she took us in
we were awakened the next morning by the
shots
a dozen people lay face down in the snow
warden didn't like to leave witnesses
they shot the woman and her family last
they made sure that we watched the whole
thing
this is your gift the warden told us
your gift and your curse
touching lives only by ending
you them him
[Music]
better than anyone
so
you